Matthew 8: 1-4 read with me when he was
come down from the mountain great
multitudes followed him and behold there
came a leper and worshiped him I love
that translation man see guys thank the
Lord Jesus for the King James Bible
because if you read the Greek word for
for worship it's
prano and yet other translations won't
translate it worship here in this
context and respect to Jesus Christ and
I'll show you what I mean but the King
James honors our Lord s our Lord by
translating the word prano when it's
used of Jesus as
worship whereas other translations will
not translate it as worship because they
doubt whether prano means that the
individuals are worshiping Jesus or
simply honoring him okay there came a
leper and worshiped him saying Lord
notice worship Lord if thou wilt thou
can make me clean if you want to you can
make me clean okay watch here
now not only is Jesus willing to make
him clean he actually touches him and
Jesus put forth his hand and touched him
saying I
will I do want to make you clean and
here let me prove it I will touch you be
thou clean and immediately his leprosy
was cleansed and Jesus saith unto him
see thou tell no man but go thy way show
thyself to the priest and offer the gift
that Moses commanded for a testimony
unto them now you guys want me do you
guys really want me to unpack this and
bring out the meat of this before I open
up the Skype you guys really want meat
okay it was forbidden according to the
law of Moses if you read Leviticus
13 right it was
forbidden for a man with an infectious
skin disease to come into contact with
anyone he would have to be quarantined
it's like covid right like
covid where you have to be in isolation
and you cannot come in contact as long
as this man had an infectious skin
disease he could not come in contact
with people and people could not touch
him now notice the beauty of our Lord
Jesus not only does he heal him but this
man for the first time in his life would
have actually experienced physical touch
you see what the Lord is doing see here
is where you need to know your Old
Testament you need to know your
Testament to see the depth of the
compassion of Jesus Christ for all this
time this man would have been
quarantined for all this time this man
would not have
had the loving compassionate Embrace of
anyone did you know that no one could
hug him no one could kiss him no one
could shake his hand no one could hold
him as long as he had that infection and
disease he'd have to be isolated and
he'd be barred from any physical display
physical acts of compassion
and you see what Jesus did he didn't
simply say I heal you he goes I'm
willing and he touched
them be
clean so I want you to see the depth of
the love of Jesus it's when I want you
to catch the depth of the love of Jesus
before I move
on you with me
there yes he's a leper it's right there
XYZ read it infectious skin disease okay
secondly if you were to touch a man with
leprosy or infectious skin disease okay
you would be contaminated ceremonially
You' be considered ceremonially unclean
and you have to Bar yourself at least to
the evening and then be
washed now notice what Jesus is doing
from a human perspective from Human
observation he was violating the law of
Moses
okay violating the law of Moses because
he touched the man which was forbidden
by the law so from a a perspective of a
Jew who doesn't know Jesus who Jesus is
by touching him they would see he's in
violation of the
law so then why did Jesus touch him
because he's teaching you a very
powerful lesson about who he is yes it's
true that if you you an ordinary human
being a sinner come into contact with a
man with leprosy or infectious skin
disease you'll be contaminated by it I
on the other hand I am impeccable
infallible perfectly righteous and pure
no contamination can contaminate me
because with one touch of my my body all
contaminants are erased eradicated wiped
out of existence and in other words you
can't defile me but I can purify you
with one
touch you understand what the Lord just
did do you you guys understand the
implication of that or no I don't want
to move on whereas if I touched him I'd
be contaminated Jesus saying there's
nothing in creation that can defile me
there's nothing in creation that can
contaminate me there's nothing in
creation that can make me impure I am am
immutably
pure impeccable infallible diseases and
contaminants are wiped out of existence
when they come in contact with
me you
see did you catch
it did you catch
it in doing that Jesus is showing he's
God In the
Flesh because ordinary human beings
ordinary Jews could not touch a man with
Leprosy because they would come in
violation of the law but he No Ordinary
Jew he's God In the Flesh who can do
what no Jew can do with one touch he
destroys
diseases he eradicates diseases he wipes
out contaminants and diseases out of
existence okay further confirmation that
what Jesus did is a clear indication he
is God further confirmation that Jesus
is God I'm going to invite you at your
own
Leisure to read 2 Kings chapter 5 the
entire chapter we're not going to read
it now okay are you with me there are
you
listening when you have time please read
2 Kings 5 in its entirety prayerfully
and slowly why because Naman was the
general of the army of Syria he had
infectious
leprosy and so he was told there's a man
in Israel
Elisha Elisha who is a prophet of God
who can heal so Naman sent word to the
King right the King was upset and
livid that Naman was asking to be cured
because the king assume this was a
pretext for the Syrian Army to attack
and if if you read it if you read the
chapter the king says am I
God am I
God he's asking his leprosy to be clean
am I go understand that the response of
the king shows you that even the
Israelites realize only God could
cleanse
leprosy right that's the response read
it it's there in chapter five I'm not
making up second kingans 5
so he's told well no Prophet Elisha the
prophet of God can do something for him
so Naman comes now here's where the
story gets
beautiful the servant of n of Elisha
Elisha does not come out to greet him he
stays in the house the servant of Elisha
and I believe his name is jei j haai if
my memory doesn't fail me because I'm
very bad with names and geography so
don't condemn me if I'm wrong here okay
he tells him to tell Naman to dip
himself in the Jordan River seven times
now man is living and upset because
Elisha doesn't come out to greet him but
Nan's servant tells him listen you've
come this far just do as the prophet
says so it's Elisha not
Elijah Elisha not Elijah so now Watch
What Happens Watch What Happens he goes
into the Jordan River dips himself seven
times and when he comes out the seven
time his skin is as fresh and healthy as
baby skin miraculously healed
prefiguring the Perfection of water
baptism in that in the act of water
baptism the Holy Spirit comes upon you
to make you a new creation and to
cleanse you of your spiritual
leprosy you got it a picture of water
baptism and how God would use water
baptism to confer upon you the almighty
living Holy Spirit who then makes you a
new creation unites you to Christ and
eradicates your spiritual
leprosy every with me so
far but I got a little more to share
with you do you know why Elisha did not
come out oh by the way before I move on
let's keep it notice the Jordan River
that's the same Jordan River that's
split for Joshua and the Israelites to
cross over the same Jordan River that
was made Hollow Sanctified by Jesus
coming there and being dipped by John in
the Jordan River Sanctified by his holy
physical body that same Jordan
River everyone with me
there I move on notice the Jordan River
now do you understand why Elisha did not
come out to meet
Naman do you know
why does anyone know why he didn't come
out to meet
Naman can someone tell me why he didn't
go and meet the the the general of the
army of Syria so that God Alone gets the
credit for the miracle not Elisha to
confirm but the king said this is
something only God can do so he stayed
inside so that when he goes into the
Jordan River seven times no one can say
Elisha did it God Alone is the cause of
that
healing that's why he never went out
because what did the king say am I God
what he's asking me I don't have the
power of life or death he's asking me
something only God can do so Elisha
stayed in the house so that when he went
and dipped himself in the Jordan River
seven times and he was miraculously
healed all credit would go to the god of
Israel not to Elisha his human
instrument Angie it has nothing to do
with him being a sinner because Elisha
and Elijah did many miracles as
Sinners right so now tie it in with
Jesus what is this tell you about
Jesus who touched a man physically and
with one touch miraculously healed them
of his
leprosy what does that tell
you Jesus is doing what second king says
God Alone can do and
does right so you saw that everyone are
you catching it Jesus is doing which no
one in record Biblical history has ever
done touch a man physically and cure him
of his leprosy leprosy instantaneously
miraculously on the
spot see these are
hints by the Bible writers showing you
that Jesus is God In the Flesh hints
that we don't see because we're not
grounded in the Old
Testament are you catching it if we're
grounded in the Hebrew Bible these are
little
nuggets why do you think I titled it
nuggets from Matthew
nuggets that the holy spirit is giving
us through these authors to reveal the
true identity of Jesus he's the god of
Israel in the flesh nuggets that if you
know your Old Testament you will see it
oh wow he touched them but the law says
he can't touch him because then he'll be
ceremonially unclean but not not only
did he touch him he instantly cured him
something unheard of in the entire
history of the Old
Testament right